if you think about every piece of your
business right now
all of the people that report to you
there's typically a metric that you're
trying to push
but something you're trying to also
conversely not have happen
[Music]
uh i'll make this a short one for you i
just got off a call
uh with a company that i have a vested
interest in um
and so uh we were talking about how to
set up the
management metrics uh in place for the
business as we're trying to scale it
and so one of uh one of the things i
picked up from andy grove in uh
shoot what is called high output
management i think um
is paired metrics and um
it was it was just a great epiphany for
me and so i'm going to share it with you
so the way that any growth who's the
founder of intel very smart
dude manages each of the roles within
the company is that he tries to put
paired metrics in place so it's not just
number of sales or just closing
percentage
or just insert one thing here right
most times and this is just myself
included i would usually should be like
this is the one key metric that i want
to look at right this is the one thing
that matters for this position
but if you think a little bit more about
it um it tends to be
two that are in parallel all right and
so what it does is help you
helps you manage the balance or the
dichotomy between
the performance enroll and typically
it'll be between
speed or output in terms of total volume
and
quality all right and so the way that
you balance this within any position
would be
for example if you're talking to a
salesperson it would be total number of
sales
against refunds back outs all right
if you're looking at a customer service
position it might be
speed of ticket resolution or total
number of tickets handled
and customer satisfaction or uh
nps or like a promoter score right uh so
that would be a balance between
two different metrics that you're that
you're looking at and then that way
because at the end of the day
you you never really want to because a
lot of times in business it's not about
either extreme it's about managing a
dichotomy of being uh am i being
micromanaging
or am i delegating too much right like
is either of them wrong
no you want to follow kind of right in
that middle path and
in different times you might lean
towards one area or the other
area more but when you're looking at
each component of the business
you can look at balance metrics and so
um i'll break down more examples because
i think it might be useful for you so if
you're looking at a marketing position
it's going to be total number of
applications
against qualified applications right
so it's like okay this is the total
volume i got but how many were qualified
right
um the next would be the sales guy which
i just went over like
total sales volume or closing percentage
against backouts
all right the service position uh total
number of uh
responses and or tickets uh handled or
customer uh complaints resolved or speed
of resolution
against uh the quality score right
um on the back end let's see i'm trying
to think of other positions that you can
have for this
uh i mean like
right now obviously because i'm live um
but if you think about every
piece of your business right now all of
the people that report to you
there's typically a metric that you're
trying to push but something you're
trying to also
conversely not have happen and so if you
can
define both of those things for the
person then you can push as hard as you
can
on the top the top side right the speed
or the volume metric
and balance it so another example is if
you're in a physical products business
it would be inventory against shortages
right you don't want to have
tons and tons of inventory because
that's not good you have lots of cash
that's sitting there
it's not good for the business it's
dangerous for the business but
if you just say hey i want you to just
keep our inventories as low as possible
right then you're going to start having
shortages right and so you want to
balance
inventory against shortages and then
that's the metric that you're reporting
on for that position right so for me
that would be my finest department who's
managing
that component of our business in the
supplement side right um
uh taxes versus audits
right or i you know any kind of issue
that you have the irs and so with each
of these
things that have you have the positive
thing which you're going for against the
negative thing you're trying to
avoid and so um i want to call this the
sweet spot which clearly i didn't and
i'll name it later
um but that's the managing the dichotomy
in management
using parallel metrics will get you so
much closer to the sweet spot of optimum
performance for each of these roles
and also going through the mental
exercise for yourself will help you to
find those things
for each of the roles in your business
and ultimately
the only thing that's going to allow you
to scale the business uh if you're in
the service space which many of the
people are listening
are is initially it's going to be your
ability to to train people and onboard
people right so assuming your culture
and your training your training gets
them up and going culture keeps them
going right
um and then the keeping them going is
making sure that you're monitoring the
right things for them
so you can get the outcome that you
really want right and so um i just had
this uh call with
the founder of that business that i'm
now invested in um and we were talking
about how we're setting
that business up to scale so that each
of the roles that we have
um get balanced out and so for there we
have
uh image editors so we can see the total
number of images they're edited it's a
photography based business um
against the number of callbacks or
corrections that need to happen
and so you can see this in virtually
every position that exists within your
business
but if you simply look at that name them
and explain it to the person then
they'll understand
everything that you want and then you'll
ultimately make more money and then they
will feel
like they have more clarity and if they
don't understand how to do those things
then you train right and that's the
entire that's the whole game
is you train them you give them the two
metrics you walk the middle and then
that is how you maintain
uh high level performance over an
organization so
um shout out to andy grove for being
smarter than uh me
hopefully that was useful for you for me
that was a huge takeaway uh when i was
going through his book
um and so use it make more money have
higher profits
have a happier team have a happy
wednesday lots of love catch you soon
you